the size of the blockchain is already an
issue one of the problems we're
interested in for example is how do you
extend mobile payments to villagers in
the third world that don't have mobile
phone service and some people suggest
that you use blockchain for this but
that's completely infeasible because the
blockchain is already several gigabytes
in size and it's growing all the time
and unless you've got a broadband
connection you basically can't play in
this game so where you have got
restricted environments where you've got
no communications are very slow and
intermittent communications using
Bitcoin mechanisms is seriously
difficult
the problem with Bitcoin as little
thought it's got some very attractive
characteristics it's also got some
downsides rusty it doesn't have the
necessary skill Bitcoin transactions are
going through you know of the order of
one transaction per second but if you
wanted to compete seriously with Visa or
MasterCard especially in the run-up to
Christmas you'd need to be doing at
least a thousand times a second second
the sheer volumes of money that you
would need if you were to process into
bank transactions for example would be
several orders of magnitude larger third
there are all sorts of issues around
failure and recourse at present if
you've got a payment system you
basically have to run a helpdesk that
you have to run a fraud detection
service in an asset recovery service and
so on so that if something goes wrong
you've got somebody to call and that's a
requirement in Europe with the payment
services directive but Bitcoin has none
of that if somebody hacks your computer
and steals your Bitcoin wallet there's
nobody you can form the money is be
retrieve ibly gone so from that reason
there's some debate about whether
bitcoin is actually a currency at all
and I personally tend to see it simply
as being something like a an industrial
bearer bond you know a digital
equivalent of a gold coin so there's a
number of systems called art coins which
also use the blockchain mechanism this
idea of building distributed consensus
by getting the players in the system to
do some cryptographic work to find a
hash which in turn then creates the
distributed consensus so there's a
number of variants on the theme have
been proposed and some are actually used
for real value then of course there are
systems that are a little bit like
traditional banking systems EMV clones
mobile payment systems which are used by
payment services operators in various
parts of the world and that has been the
growth area over the past ten years
mobile payment systems like in peso in
Kenya which use you know old-fashioned
1980s cryptographic methodology
basically encrypted SMS messages to
bring banking services to people who can
benefit
from them and her too far away from the
conventional bank branch and then there
have been some exotic systems that have
been academic ties such as digi cash
which was invented by David Chow in the
1980s and that uses fancy cryptography
in order to see to it that transactions
are anonymous and unlink Abel right so I
could have a digital kind that I spend
with you and you could then spend it
with somebody else and they would have
no way of telling that you had got that
coin from me and that's the exact
opposite of Bitcoin and it's got its own
problems basically you end up having to
rely on a combination of fancy
cryptography and some tamper resistance
and it's been used so far only on a
fairly small scale we hear these stories
of people searching dumps for hard disks
because they've left it a Bitcoin wallet
on it what does the wallet look like is
that something like the blockchain
itself is it like a small version of
that like a list of stuff for a Bitcoin
wallet is simply a piece of software
that you can run on your PC or your
laptop or your phone which will keep
track of your coins and which will
contain critically the the cryptographic
key the signing key that you use to sign
over your coins to somebody else now in
the Bitcoin world your identity is a
public key and public keys and private
keys are generated in pairs such that
the private key is the secret you have
that can be used to sign stuff and the
public key which is in effect your name
in the Bitcoin system
it's what anybody else can use to verify
your signature so if I pay money to you
I don't pay money to you as a person I
pay money to the private key that you've
told me corresponds to your wallet
professor you're an expert in this
financial world and technology so in
your opinion it is this perhaps a
template for how things might be evolved
in the future or is it what do you think
about this is a kind of starting point
Bitcoin doesn't quite work as a new
global currency for a number of reasons
firstly there's the size of the
blockchain secondly does the delay a
reasonable delay
transaction booked in might be about an
hour because you have to wait for more
than one hash to be sure the transaction
has gone through in its final a third
problem is the lack of recourse if
something goes wrong there's nobody to
fund a fourth problem is that over time
as the amount of money available to
miners goes down so the willingness of
people to do Bitcoin mining might go
down and the system is certainly going
to have to change it may even face a
crisis if it's no longer possible for
people to borrow money from the bank in
order to buy Bitcoin mining equipment
which is already beginning to be the
case so for a number of technical
reasons you know Bitcoin was a good
first try at building something but we
don't really know what its successor is
going to be really good at and to my way
of thinking Bitcoin is a wonderful
technology waiting for somebody to
invent it's true killer application
not off with the last hash plus all the
transactions that you've swept together
into a pool to answer the chin and then
there's the hash that you found at the
end it's also problem of AI safety is
not solved is not going to solve itself
and is not easy to solve